well let's start with this prices have
gone up prices surging more than they
have in 30 years the cost for just about
everything is trending higher the
consumer price index spiking 6.2 percent
our experts believe and the data shows
that most of the price increases we've
seen are were expected and expected to
be temporary i mean it's like it's not
that hard to understand when dana said
you pump 10 trillion dollars into the
economy
[Music]
if you think about inflation it is what
is driving financial returns for
majority of the people that are making
money in the market today it is also the
thing that is driving many of the people
who are actually going into a worse
financial position at the same time
inflation is the key to finance and
investing right now now as we talked
about yesterday the cpi number hit 5.4
in june that's the highest it's been in
13 years if you take out the food and
energy sectors uh the core inflation
number is 4.5 that's the highest it's
been in 30 years we are at historic
rates of inflation during most people's
lifetime the white house is smarter than
you think
the politicians are smarter than you
think
inflation is raging at the highest
levels we've seen in years
cpi officially is being reported at 5.4
percent that's the highest that cpi has
been in 13 years
core inflation is
4.3 percent that is in june and july the
highest in 30 years now when you have
high rates of inflation four to five
percent what that means is you have to
increase
the amount of money that you are making
by four to five percent
simply to keep up with inflation that is
the only way that you can protect your
purchasing power but now we have seen
that the house of representatives your
elected leader
are deciding that they are going to
raise the maximum annual salary for
their staff
to 199
300 dollars that's right the staff for
the house of representatives the maximum
they can make now is 700 below 200 grand
that is up from 173
900
so what that tells you is that the house
of representatives your elected leaders
the same people who are telling you
listen to the economist don't worry
about inflation this is transitory
have chosen to increase the pay
of their own staffers by about 14
chipotle you're an hourly worker you get
three or four percent raise you work at
an investment bank like a blackrock you
get eight percent but you work for the
government you get a 14 raise and so
what we are seeing is the classic don't
listen to what they're saying watch what
they're doing we have breaking news the
new york federal reserve just came out
with revised inflation expectations what
are we thinking
the new york federal reserve now sees
inflation
still above five percent one year from
today
[Music]
they believe three years from today on a
percent piece it'll be over four percent
and a series high with large expected
price rises in food rent and medical
costs
[Laughter]
so basically everything you spend money
on is going to go up
here's the craziest part
if inflation is still above five percent
a year from now
that's five percent above
where it is today which is five percent
above where it was a year ago yeah
we now are in compounding territory
ladies and gentlemen put on your helmet
strap in your seat belts do not talk
while the pilot takes off because we are
gonna start compounding at a rate that
you cannot imagine the big news this
morning is that the inflation numbers
were released for september as we have
been telling you non-stop since last
year inflation is not transitory the cpi
number came in at 5.4 percent this is a
13 year high the cpi the core or i'm
sorry the consumer price index is as
high as it was during the financial
crisis absolutely insane core inflation
came in at four percent you see here we
have first the tweet u.s september
consumer prices increase 5.4
from one year earlier core cpi up four
percent over a year we'll get to core in
a second and the nonsense that that is
but first let's start with the consumer
price index 5.4 percent is that crazy is
it not well let's look on a relative
basis if we look around the world at all
of the different in cpi numbers they're
year over year percent change what we
find is that the u.s sucks
simple
just real simple the us sucks the only
countries that are doing better from an
inflation standpoint are venezuela
argentina turkey brazil russia mexico
and poland today the inflation numbers
came out we hit a 31-year high this is
absolutely historic and it is frankly
sad breaking us inflation was up
6.2 percent in october from a year ago
the year-over-year change of consumer
prices according to cpi index is
6.2 percent the official numbers it's
the highest inflation in 31 years
inflation was up 0.9
in october alone a much higher increase
than 0.4 percent in september and 0.3 in
august prices are rising for food energy
shelter used cars and new cars
absolutely bonkers what we are watching
right now we continue to see not only
high inflation not only persistently
high inflation but we are seeing
accelerating inflation it is getting
worse it is not getting better well
let's start with this prices have gone
up